you guys have some more videos showing
off some of the coolest ships in
Starfield so let's do it again this is a
gunship nice little pistol Desert Eagle
design they've got going on here I want
to see it flying this one's from someone
called com crisis on Reddit I absolutely
love this one this ship is a literal
ship clearly Titanic based design and
now she gets to fly to outer space She's
Gotta watch out for comets and Ice
planets I wonder if she'll attract some
billionaires and submarines it was
submitted by Jethro Wilson on the stop
field separated this one
I mean looks awesome but it's from
Reddit user vetland and they said pretty
proud of this design Max Mobility almost
Max Speed 6 000 cargo and all stations
this is just like finesse shipbuilding
so this person sp7r said they had 50
hours of play time and 40 was spent in
the ship Builder and this is their
latest build the Black Widow I think
this might be the same person who shared
the Scorpion from last time